[Music]
good morning Goldie my name is God and I
live in free City I have everything I
[Music]
need except one thing hey excuse me
hey hey bud you ever think that there's
got to be more more than what it's stuff
we do day after day literally not once
today's going to be different Goldie
what are we looking
at who are you we ran into each other
the other day how did you find me I
waited outside by the murder
train guys I have to tell you something
there's no easy way to say this this
world it's a video
game I really want to kiss you is that
weird listen to me you're not
[Music]
real wait you let who kiss you guy
there's not a button for that oh oh he
found the
button buddy if we're not real doesn't
that mean that nothing you do matters I
am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time now if that's not real I don't know
what it is Millie I know this world is
just a game but this place these people
that's all I
have thanks Guy who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads by being the good
guy woo blue shirt guy you're absolutely
right who is he or she indeed this loser
is ruining the game man I don't care if
he's Arnold freak and schaten Vader
terminate
him we're doing great guy in 2 days the
game is going to shut down you this
whole city they be gone what if we can
save
it
was that cool it felt really cool we can
change our world but we have to fight
together I don't even know what's
happening right now but I love it this
is the first time I've ever driven a car
before I really wish you'd mention that
yeah
yeah we love you Blue sh thank you watch
out for
the this seem
nice
[Music]
you